machine à café frigo ou encore
laveelinge ce n'est peut-être pas
visible mais ces appareils ont déjà du
vécu c'est l'association envie attrape
qui leur a donné une seconde vie donc
j'ai cette machine
là qui est arrivé sous garantie donc le
problème qu'elle avait c'est que la cuve
était carrément tombée on avait le la
traverse là qui était cassée donc je
l'ai
remplacé et là je m'aperçois qu'elle
disjoncte donc c'est un problème de
résistance hors garantie le coût de
cette opération s'élèverait à 150 €.
grâce à ce système le client économise
en ne rachetant pas de nouvelles
machines le fait de bah juste changer la
résistance c'est bénéfique déjà pour la
la planète puisque ça nous évite de le
fer à la poubelle et puis bah c'est
réparable en vrai tout est réparable des
cas comme celui-là envie en compte un
bon nombre installé à trappe depuis 11
ans l'entreprise reconditionne entre 200
à 300 appareils chaque mois un phénomène
qui s'observe notamment depuis la mise
en place du bonus réparation c'est un
dispositif qui a été mis en place il y a
environ un an et qui
permet à propriétaire d'une machine en
panne de bénéficier d'une remise chez
des réparateurs agréés les réparates
agré qu'elle répare des bonus qui vont
de de 10 à 45 € envie compte aujourd'hui
52 établissements en France à terme elle
souhaite développer un centre de
formation dédié à ses futurs salariés